and we got a we got a [ __ ] special
guest here man and I'm really
intimidated by this guy because he
raised me um we got Pauly Shore in the
housekeeping round of applause everybody
we got Pauly Shore in the house bro well
why you making the face might learn to
talk now you can talk now once I
introduce you bro so now it's now you're
sound like a [ __ ] Mexican April hey
um but before we get started because
they know you're gonna go in the whole
thing like I was your landlord I want to
ask your girl a question yeah yeah
what's it like having sex with Bobby for
real not jokingly not just like a
performance-art situation where it's a
it's it's a full psychological
experience no real like the seat does he
go down on you and stuff yeah he likes
it yeah we play let me finish open with
this oh boy asking my girl about that
well I just wanted to know because I
think you're lucky I am yeah Oh No thank
you for one time finally somebody knows
thank your lot to get did you get to be
next to him oh it's a it's a gift right
it's like being with a human and a pet
at the same time I think it's just your
place and then there's cats here and
then you got Bobby yeah right yeah and
he's like a little pet yeah um start
from the beginning can we start from the
beginning or wander all right first of
all can I just say this why do you think
that you know that I'm not Chinese right
right what am i you're Korean all right
so but how come for the last 25 years
every time I see in your [ __ ] eyes
look super Chinese dude I don't know
what to say
[Laughter]
yeah very good observation yeah you're
more like Filipino oh you wouldn't call
him Chinese no no only me I love Chinese
because of my eyes yeah I mean you look
you know you look very Asian
[Laughter]
yeah but like since I've known you when
you bring me up on stage you always go
Chinese people all that kind of stuff
not doing that I know but you did at the
spa the other night I can't help it we
go to the Korean spa there's a bunch of
Koreans in it standing around and I
don't even plan to meet Paul there I
just run into him in there right and I
won't even know he's there I'm taking a
shower and then I love us all here we
are the luckiest and then I'll turn
around and I'll have a panic attack
oh my god he's here he's here he's here
right no what happens is is you know
we're in this life of ours you don't I
mean we're all going through different
things like you know stress and [ __ ]
like Bobby gets depressed you don't I
mean we all get to press we get sad and
stuff like that and the asian spa the
Korean spa is the only place that Bobby
can go to feel really comfortable and
feel really like oh I can finally let go
yeah you know I'm not around anyone know
around my agents my girl no movies no TV
I can just be here by myself and he goes
in there and he's scrubbing his little
[ __ ] vagina I think I found me it's
like I cornered the animal scream I'm
like Chinese Chinese baby
yeah just like [ __ ] gets its whole
face gets sad
and then literally he makes the spa his
it like with him he does it really quick
three minutes and he leaves your name me
yeah can't really enjoy yourself knowing
that I'm there yeah you do feel that
then yeah can I always think I'm being
slide now I gotta go I know you don't
want I love you you know I love you but
you don't go in the coat you don't go
into the hot you don't go into the high
you just did it yeah I did and then I go
to the cold plunge I leave yeah yeah
every time but I love it there because I
love to be able to you know I see them
in and half of them I'd say I've been
going there for so long I actually have
a pass yeah you bought up I think I'm
the only white person that has a pass
yeah one year passed she have been $900
you can go all the
yeah and then you I'm Jewish so I start
doing the math I'm like is it worth it
how many times a week do I go here yeah
and I go probably about five times a
week
Wow you do yeah it's the best right
because it's low-key yeah
the steam room is super hot yeah and you
love Asian people obsessed yes so it's
like everything and why yeah yeah and
the ladies so mean at the front which we
love I love that yeah yeah who do you
mean she so mean she's so mean she's so
[ __ ] man don't even they won't even
look at you something they'll just go
and they'll throw you the key like
you're garbage
oh I love it yeah yeah and then there
was like a center of a sex thing going
on there yeah but did you ever figure
that out or no I tried you because the
chicks are [ __ ] hot yeah yeah yeah
then like they wouldn't let any white
people in there at all yeah one Road in
and said that her brother was actually
part of I don't want to put him out that
he was part of the vice squad that
busted them and it was some type of what
you guys were talking about it was they
would they have a very oaky but it was
it was not very Asian ladies and white
type of material yeah I try to get in I
remember you one night you go how do you
do it and they're like no not go dick
because I've seen your dick - you have a
very big dick for your size mm right I
don't I mean it's beautiful
mmm it's curved you know me there's like
I'm veiny you know yeah his dick is
pretty pure yeah yeah yeah that felt
like when I was in your but when I'm
back in the 90s
[Music]